good morning good afternoon or good
evening
and i thank the committee very much for
allowing me to present
this work to this conference i also want
to thank the committee for
forcing me to put on a bow tie it's been
a minute and it
quite frankly feels pretty good so today
i will be
presenting work from my team at roche
sequencing solutions
on a new tumor sampling method that we
believe
addresses the heterogeneity that we see
in solid tumors
first some acknowledgements you can see
the team on the left it's a pretty small
team we have some very active
and very fruitful collaborations with
the francis crick institute and the
royal marsden hospital both in london
specific call-outs to charles swanton
and samuel turlich for their
considerable help in trying to pioneer
this new
processing method that i'll show you in
a few minutes
so my team is really interested in the
diversity at the cellular
the genomic and the transcriptomic level
of solid tumors
one of the challenges we have though as
as a community of scientists
is that the way that we are currently
sampling tumors
leads to bias in the data that we
get from the solid tumors that we're
sampling you can see this
on the cartoon on the right this shows
three different
biopsies taken from a tumor that has
some variable areas of heterogeneity
and as you can see each of those samples
delivers different data sets both on the
genomic and then
in a more general biomarker sense
so we believe that to really capture
the diversity of solid tumors we have to
rethink how we're sampling
in the pathology lab and if you think
about
electoral polling or
the mining industry where the goal is to
try and capture
the most representative sample of a
spatially segregated sample
the the tool that they use is called
representative sampling
and as you can see here as we click
through the animation
this is a very straightforward process
that has been used as i mentioned in a
couple of different industries
it's based on statistics that were
defined back in the early 1950s
by a mathematician who was in the mining
industry named pierre gee
and essentially what it says is that you
take a spatially segregated sample
you homogenize it and then every sample
you take
will contain the diversity of the
original lot
in every aliquot and you can see that
represented in this cartoon
so essentially this is what we are
attempting to do
and as i hope to convince you through
this talk
in doing so we we generate some very
interesting data and we capture
diversity that is lost in single
biopsies
so to just touch briefly
on how we currently sample solid tumors
i'm very aware that many pathologists
are are probably watching this and
invited to this
to the seminar series so i'm not going
to belabor the point on the left
where we have a couple of diagrams of
the standard samples taken for the tnm
sampling and staging and here you can
see
a lung and a kidney tumor and
you know the the samples are taken many
times are taken
with the tumor and the normal tissue
such that you can look at the interface
for many reasons these samples are
critically important
so that we can stage the tumor
appropriately which
is both prognostic and very important
when we discuss
designing treatment regimens for
patients however
a single sample cannot capture the
diversity of
the entire tumor mass this is very well
demonstrated in the literature both from
from charles swann
samara and and artwork
the the challenge that we have is that
that spatial bias taking a single sample
from one area
leaves you blind to biomarkers that are
present throughout
the rest of the tumor this is also
described as clonal illusion
on the right here you can see data that
is uh
taken from a paper that we just recently
published in cell reports
litchfield at all in in the data that
you see on the right what we did is we
did a survey of 76 samples
of colorectal melanoma and sarcoma
and we looked at what is the average
size
of these tumors and then what is the
median percent of that tumor
that made it into a pcr test
in which three 10 micron sections were
taken
for purification of dna
and as you can see if we just focus on
the far right
you know the the tumors themselves are
about on average the size of a ping pong
ball
whereas the amount of tumor that makes
it into the pcr test is point zero zero
zero five percent and what this does is
this generates the law of small numbers
the law of small numbers is yet another
sort of cognitive bias where samples
that are not representative
tend to generate variable data
especially
when we look at biomarkers or really
any types of data that are present at
low prevalence
so if you have something that is say ten
percent across
a cohort of a thousand patients say
there are many many times though you
will just miss that and you will not
understand really the the total
diversity in that study and this is
really one of the things that we believe
um this process is going to help with
across the board
so this is a cartoon that demonstrates
our workflow
on the top you can see that the current
tissue workflow for surgically resected
solid tumors
surgery happens the tissue goes into
formula and fixation
the samples for the tnm staging are
taken
and those will be ffpe blocks those
blocks
sections are cut and those go through
the standard
diagnostic modalities that exist today
in the clinic
a really important point here is that
the
sample that we are using samples that we
are homogenizing
consist of the residual tumor tissue
that is not incorporated into ffpe
blocks we are not
using ffp blocks we are using the stuff
that gets put in
to trash and today is almost universally
incinerated
with the notable exception of these
samples being
bio-banked by a number of different
companies and institutions
what we are doing is we are having a
surgical pathologists or pathologist
assistants dissect out the rest of the
tumor
and a portion of normal as you can see
on the bottom
we then homogenize these samples
creating
essentially a liquid tumor of that solid
tumor
we then use the normal as the control
when we uh sequence
the tumor and um this has essentially
been
the basis of the work that went into the
the paper that i mentioned
in cell
one point that i would like to point out
again just to repeat
we are not using ffpd blocks many times
i do get questions about this
and we are only using the formalin fixed
tissue
that remains after the tnm staging that
goes back into the bucket and waits
until sign off
so here's just a brief presentation
overview
today i'll be talking briefly about some
ngs downstream of representative
sampling this is
we call this rep seek this is sort of
the foundation of the
paper that i mentioned earlier but then
i want to get into some really
interesting stuff
um where we've we furthered our
methodology
such that we have enabled flow cytometry
of intact cells from fixed
formal and fixed tumors and then i'll
finish with
how we're trying to use the the flow
cytometry and flow sorting
to enrich for tumor cells prior to ngs
which significantly improves the data
output
so first we're going to talk a little
bit about how representative sampling
helps next generation sequencing of
solid tumors
i'm going to present just a brief uh
case report
this is of one very large kidney tumor
there's a clear cell renal cell
carcinoma
in this tumor our colleagues at the
cricket at the marsden
slice this tumor into four very large
slices
otherwise known as bread loafs from
these slices
60 punch biopsies were taken and the
remainder of the tissue
was homogenized i'll also be showing
that blood samples were taken both
pre-surgery and post-surgery
and we used many of the findings from
the homogenous to
better track the disease progression
over time
so the first and most important aspect
of representative sampling
as it relates to ngs is the fact that
when you homogenize tumors you
eliminate clonal illusion as you can see
in the top right the little pie chart
this is
essentially a brief description of what
clonal illusion is
when you take a single sample for
instance either the box
that is across the purple and the gold
slices of the pie or the single box
that's found within the green slice of
pie
both of those samples are biased because
they can't see the other
parts of the pie this is what is
described as clonal illusion
now if you were to homogenize that you
would clearly see that you would
when you end up sampling from that have
about a third purple a third gold
and a third green and this is what we
find in our case study
in this tumor there were two major
subclones
there was a subclone b and c that both
derived from the clone a
it's the parental clone and when we look
at the single biopsies in the middle
what we see is that we have inaccurate
clonality calls
of the variants that we find in the
individual biopsies
all of those 60 biopsies so for instance
we have
clonal variants from clone a that
appeared to be subclonal
but we also have variants in clones b
and c
that are subclonal that appear clonal
and just intuitively when you think
about
subclonal drivers subclonal resistance
mechanisms
seeing that these things are clonal is
not
number one the truth for that tumor and
number two
may very well impact decisions
downstream
whereas on the right when you homogenize
that tumor
and you sequence it following the
homogenization
you get very accurate frequency calls as
you can see
clone a is vastly
clonal whereas clones b and c are all
subclonal
and we've eliminated coronal illusion in
this
in this case
some additional benefits when you use
this method of repseq for this patient
what we did in the middle box is we
looked at
of those 60 individual biopsies what was
the reproducibility
of the variant calls and as you can see
the reproducibility is around 76
for any single biopsy and what that
means is any given
biopsy is likely to miss 25 percent
of the variance from any other biopsy
whereas when you homogenize you're
around 97 so it's almost
totally reproducible and this makes
sense given
you know the the mathematical
predictions of representative sampling
another benefit on the right you can see
is the number
of predicted neo antigens that you can
detect
um from the single biopsies on average
you're detecting just above
uh 160 whereas for the the homogeneous
we're detecting
uh upwards of 180. but again i think
more important than the sheer
number of neo-antigens that might be
predicted from the sequencing of these
two different types of samples
it's really important to point out that
each biopsy contains
around 70 17 excuse me percent
of those variants are thought to be
clonal
when in actuality they are subclonal and
again
um you know there's quite a bit of data
out there
suggesting that a clonal neoantigens or
the neon
are the targets that will produce a very
robust
immune response whereas subclonal
and certainly very low prevalent neo
antigens may very well
not and so our point here is that
knowing the clonality and the
appropriate clonality of a variant is
really
important when we start using next
generation sequencing
for downstream decisions for patients
so what we did um with the
initial exome sequencing that i've just
showed you um
apologies i i didn't mean to mention
that all the the data that you've seen
so far
from exome sequencing what we did is we
then took
all of the variants it was around 76
variants that we detected in this
patient
from all samples and we pulled them
together to create a personalized
targeted panel for this specific patient
we then turned that into a ct dna test
and we we sequenced dna purified
from serum that was taken before surgery
at surgery and then post surgery
and here you can see that each of the
three clones are presented
in their specific colors
and you can see that pre-surgery and at
surgery
all three clones are represented at
fairly high levels
whereas right after surgery um
160 days after surgery i should say both
clones a and b
seem to have fallen off and are
undetectable whereas clone c
predominates
however that changes when the patient is
on therapy
and clones a and b take off
clone c is undetectable and the patient
then succumbs to their disease
and the predominant clones are clone a
and p
it is interesting to note that in clone
c is present at the autopsy in plural
fluid
um but i think as i click through and
you can see
each of those variants presented as a
blue box
we have p1 which is pre-surgery p10
at surgery and p16 post surgery you can
see
that what's interesting is the top boxes
are predominantly the clonal variants
and many of those are not even
detectable
post-surgery um whereas they they all
come up
uh at uh the autopsy
it's very uh i think interesting here to
to note that
you know ct dna analysis is rather
challenging and frankly the more shots
on goal that you have that are specific
to that patient
the better outcome you're going to have
um to that end
very important to note here that on day
6 160
the the first time point after surgery
if we were to create a personalized
panel
from the single biopsies
53 of those single biopsies would have
missed
tumor burden post-surgery at the first
time point
and if you think about that that would
essentially be a minimal residual
disease false negative
so i guess our point here is that not
only is representative sampling very
important
when making decisions of those variants
that are coming out of solid tumors
specifically around the clonality of
those variants
when one then uses that sequencing data
potentially to
to make a personal ict dna monitoring
test
the more shots on goal the better and as
we've
demonstrated for this patient you you
will generally and
in all cases so far get more shots on
goal when you homogenize the tumor
versus a single biopsy
so much of that data is
presented in the paper that i mentioned
that was published in
cell reports and i'm happy to point you
in that direction
what i really am interested in
especially for this audience
is our ability to further process this
sample
and then enable it for flow cytometry
interestingly when you put a formula
fixed solid tumor in a blender
it does not become what you think it
would be
uh when we first started this i kind of
thought um well when i make
banana shakes at home i no longer see
the bananas so it must be liquefied
whereas you can see on the image on the
right
a formalin fixed solid tumor gets
chopped up into really small bits
of tumor including single cells
so we have chunks of tumor that are
comprised of many
tens of thousands of cells and single
cells but
we have preserved the unit of
heterogeneity which is the single cell
we can then further
disassociate those fragments of tumor
into single cells
using non-enzymatic methods and
more mechanical dissociation along with
filtration
and depending on the size of the tumor
we can create trillions upon trillions
of cells
both cancer cells immune cells and
stromal cells
i won't belabor this because i know that
the vast majority of people in this
audience are very familiar with flow
cytometry but just suffice it to say
that
what we are doing is again
disassociating these these solid tumors
into single cells
this is non-enzymatic so we're not
degrading the epitopes on the surface of
the cell
and then we are putting these cells
through a fluorocytometer
one important thing i think uh is
of note is that you know around 40 years
ago
in the 80s there were some papers where
people
disassociated tumors from formlin fixed
paraffin embedded samples and isolated
nuclei
which we have also done however the
formula and fixation
we find really damages the cell
membranes and creates very fragile cells
that are really not amenable to flow
cytometry which is
why i think we don't do today flow
cytometry on formula fixed cells
at least of intact cells and so i hope
to convince you in the
in the coming slides that um this method
is very robust
it's very similar to fresh and i think
has
some really interesting outputs that i
believe the
viewers of the seminar will really
really appreciate
so fixed flow is kind of what we're
calling this fixed flow is very
reproducible
as you can see in the cartoon on the
left we take a solid tumor
we homogenize it we then disassociate it
further and filtrate it
so that we create a single cell
suspension and then we stain
in three different experiments for the
same biomarker and then we look at the
variance of that
as you can see on the figure on the
right this is the reproducibility of
fixed flow
looking at two biomarkers cd3 and cd8
the coefficient of variance
is incredibly low across 30 different
patient cases
these tumor types include breast colon
kidney and lung
and if you look on the the figure in the
inset
with the colorful dots what we've done
here is
is essentially looked at the biological
relevance of the data
making sure that we're not wildly off as
cd8 is a component of cd3 positive cells
we certainly don't want to see a bunch
of cda positive cells and very few
cd83 positive cells and what you can see
here is that
the data that we're collecting here
looks very similar to
what data should like when you look at
cd8 and cd3
in some instances we have more cd3 than
we have cd8 as you can see
the two blue dots on the bottom but
suffice it to say that
the data that we're producing across
four different tumor types
is biologically uh reasonable
and as i'll show you in the next slide
pretty similar to what we get when we do
that flow from fresh tissue as well
and this is that experiment what we've
done here is we've taken a biopsy
we've split it in half and for one of
those biopsies
we fixed it in formalin overnight
and then disassociated it versus the
other biopsy that was kept fresh
and followed a standard fresh flow
protocol
as you can see in the middle these are
the the images from the flow
you can see uh also very important to
mention that when we do fresh we do have
to do live
discrimination um and it the percentage
of cells that are dead
varies across samples um but we subtract
out the dead cells we go with the fresh
cells
um very important to note but not too
surprising
we don't do that in the fixed because
all of the cells are dead
so when we look at these data on this
from the same biopsy they look
very very similar and then when we look
at these targets across
all samples all biopsies that we've done
most of them
look very very similar almost identical
and the correlation is very very tight
however when you look at the figure on
the on the far right
when you're looking at biomarkers for
macrophages
in the blue these don't necessarily look
similar
um and i think i'll just mention a
couple of things that i
uh that we believe this might be the
case we're we're looking into this a bit
further but
let me just describe what i think is
happening here
it should be noted that the antibodies
that we are using in this test
are designed by ventana for
formalin-fixed
paraffin embedded tissue they work
very well on formalin-fixed cells when
we use them for flow cytometry
that being said it is likely that not
all of these antibodies will work
very well on fresh samples
so you know the the antibodies that
we're using to mark macrophages
maybe just don't work great for fresh
macrophages
so that's one possibility the other
possibility which um
we're very interested in looking at is
whether or not
potentially some of those macrophages
are the dead cells in that live dead
discrimination
one of the reasons why we think this
could be the case and as i mentioned
we're following up is that
you know one of the challenges with the
workflow of
fresh flow cytometry is that you know
the hospital is in one location
and the research might be done at yet a
different location
and cells don't just hang out
and are hunky-dory at four degrees in
specific buffers
you know they change over time and one
of the benefits of fixed flow may very
well be that we are taking
a snapshot in time because the formalin
freezes all of the biomarkers and cells
essentially where they are um it also
definitely helps with the workflow you
can
fix these cells and wait weeks as we do
until we disassociate them
further you can disassociate these fixed
cells and then wait
a few days before you do the experiments
so
we're very interested in how this
workflow can change
you know flow cytometry and the analysis
of cells from solid tumors
but suffice it to say that these data
are very similar to fresh
very reproducible and allow us to do
some really interesting analysis of
these tumors as i'll show you in the
next slides
what can we do with this well we believe
that
this allows us to really analyze the
complexity of solid tumors
in a fundamentally new way really what
we can do is we can look
at really any cell type across an entire
solid tumor
and as you can see we can
look at any number of different cell
types so we can really
very deeply interrogate
immune cells and the types of immune
cells
that have innervated that tumor over
time
we can look at fibroblasts we can look
at the percentage of cancer cells
also we can look at endothelial cells
and what we can do is we can take the
ecology of the solid tumor
and we can describe it in its entirety
across many many many different patients
and then we can compare these patients
to each other
as you can see in this slide
here are a handful of cases that have
been processed from a clinical
feasibility study run at the the where
marsden
with samuel turlich is the pi we
are looking at melanoma ovarian kidney
sarcoma breast this is a pan cancer
study
and it's really looking at the
feasibility of homogenizing solid tumors
as you can see really these these tumors
some of them look similar and some of
them look very very different
and this is really what we're finding
across
all different tumor types that we've
looked at what this
flow cytometry of fixed tissue really
enables us is to really better
appreciate
the diversity at the cellular level of
tumor composition
here are three lung and three colon
cases that i do
specifically want to call out
specifically the stage
two tumors that you'll see both in the
lung at the top and the colon at the
bottom
so these are two tumors same stage
but they are dramatically different in
their cellular composition
for instance um lo2
just the designation that we've given it
only has 11
cancer cells whereas lo7 has
36 the percent of
cytotoxic t cells is also different
and so you can see that even tumors in
the same stage
look very very different from each other
and frankly lo2
that is a stage tumor stage 2 tumor
looks
very similar to lo9 which is
the stage 3 tumor to the left so we just
find these differences to be very very
interesting
the same can be shown down in the bottom
with the colon
again we have very different percentages
of cancer cells
but very strikingly we have in co8
13 cytotoxic t cells whereas in co6 we
only have four percent
um we haven't uh followed up on this
again because all of these patients
and this tissue is taken at surgery all
of this work is
uh prospective so we don't necessarily
have
a deep follow-up and certainly not
five-year follow-up
on any of these cases but it's very
interesting to think what the difference
between 13
cytotoxic t cells and four in the same
stage
of the same tumor type might might
generate relative to
response to immunotherapy
so i'm going to end the talk here by
presenting
um some really interesting data that i
think a lot of you
might be very interested in especially
as
many i believe in the audience are
anatomical pathologists
what we're interested to do here is we
are looking to
enrich for the tumor population using
flow sorting such that we are getting a
more
pure next generation sequencing library
before we sequence these tumors both
saving
sequencing reads and frankly saving
money
so when we sequence bulk populations
we are spending quite a few sequencing
reads on normal cells and if we're
interested in the variance from cancer
frankly those reads are are wasted um
you can see
the if you look into the tcga
and many other repositories of
sequencing data for solid tumors
purity of those tumors is a very
significant challenge
and in many instances very strict
incoming criteria have to be made
such that cases can be sequenced and
this is also true in
clio labs and other labs doing clinical
sequencing
you know it's really important to have a
specific
percentage of those reads be cancer
because anything say under 20 percent
is really going to be at risk when we're
thinking about sequencing of solid
tumors
on the bottom right here you can see
again two different tumors from
this clinical study called whole stuff
run out of the marsden the tumor on the
left has
around 25 cancer cells whereas the tumor
on the right
has uh around 60 cancer cells
so those are two very different outcomes
when we're thinking about sequencing
the the tumor on the left is going to uh
we're going to have to sequence that to
much higher depth to get the equivalent
depth of the tumor on the right
um which will potentially cost time and
maybe even resequencing
so our goal here is to use the same
methodology that enables
low cytometry of these fixed samples and
then
sort these tumors to enrich for cancer
cells
prior to creating our ngs library
so you can see here in in this series of
figures
the benefit of doing this relative to to
sequencing depth and
output in the bottom left
this is a colon tumor that was sorted
based on cytokine 818
and you can see here that on the bottom
left 44 percent of that tumor was ck818
positive we then sequenced
both the homogeneous the mixed
population of cells
and the enriched tumor and you can see
in the top right
that the flow enriched sample which is
the cells that were sorted based on
cytokine 818
had almost a doubling in tumor purity
even at the same sequencing depth and so
our tumor cell coverage
is more than doubled which then
generates on the far right
65 additional variants that we find
versus in the homogenous there were only
five variants we did not find in the
flow enriched
and those five variants hovered around
five percent which was our cut-off
more importantly those 65 additional
variants
better enabled us to understand
the complexity at the level of the
phylogenetic tree
of this specific case so you can see in
the homogeneous when we look at it we
only really see two subclones very
similar to the kidney tumor that i
i showed you as our original test case
whereas when we sort this tumor we see
that there are
three additional clones that weren't
even found in that module
moreover we see that one of those clones
has
what we described as a leaf on it so an
even further
uh subclone that is from that population
on the far left and orange
so not only does enriching for
cancer cells can generate higher tumor
cell coverage
but it also can enable us to better
understand the evolutionary trajectory
of solid tumors
so we have done this across samples from
our clinical
feasibility study here we have breast
ovarian gist and kidney on the left
you can see that in all four cases we
consistently have enrichment
from the homogeneity and on the right
every time we do enrich we detect more
variants
in some instances we detect more than
double the number of variants in the
homogeneity
and in other cases we find around you
know 20 to
30 more variants suffice it to say that
these data are incredibly helpful when
we're trying to look at what i mentioned
earlier which is the
the clonal solutions of these tumors
relative to the potential evolutionary
trajectories
so when we think about enrichment
relative to clinical findings
i do want to point out one specific case
that one of the kidney cases that i just
showed you
so in this case we had three ffpe blocks
and when we do exome sequencing
what we see is that um in
ffpe block 1 we have a clonal
vhl mutation and we can see a low
prevalence baf1 mutation
however an ffp block number two we only
see the vhl clonal mutation and we miss
the bat
one and in ffpe3 the bap1
g194a mutation appears to be clonal
that is clonal illusion whereas it's
actually subclone
however in the the sordid repseq not
only do we
totally define that the vhl is a clonal
variant
we better define the actual prevalence
of the first pap one
mutation and we see a second
subclonal backbone mutation so we have a
convergence on this bap1
mutation through multiple mechanisms
and we describe that as convergent
evolution and this is important
um and if we look at this relative to
the outcome
of patients with these molecular
features and this is
data taken from uh samurai turlich at
all
it was a cell paper back in 2018
a vhl only mutation those patients had a
very very positive
outcome whereas when you have a back one
mutation
that accompanies a clonal vhl mutation
those patients do not have
as good of an outcome and so really what
we're showing here is that not only are
we
able to with representative sampling
followed up by
next generation sequencing capable of
defining
the true mutant allele frequency of
these very important clinical
variants we can also detect more
clinical variants that do
have very important outcomes um
relative to progression-free survival
and overall survival and in this case
it's very important to note that
were we to have chosen ffp block 2
we would have only seen the vhl clonal
mutation in that patient
would have had a prognosis that was
actually quite rosy
whereas in fact they had a disease that
would
progress much faster
so i'd like to summarize this talk by
again just presenting that
representative sampling does capture the
diversity
at the genomic and the cellular level of
solid tumors
in a mathematically powered way versus
single samples
um it's important to note here that
i think many of the people watching this
this seminar will understand
the sheer amount of solid tumor tissue
that is incinerated
there are hundreds of thousands of
patients where this is likely happening
and i hope that you're at least a little
convinced that that data
that's in that tissue could be very
important
when considering how is the diversity of
the ecology
and the diversity of the genomics of
cancer patients playing a role
in outcome and i think that
if we as a community reassess
using a very statistically standard
methodology of surveying and sampling
it's used in electoral polling in the
mining industry
we can begin extracting those data sets
and
better powering our studies to truly
understand how heterogeneity is playing
a role
in solid tumor biology
and progression we can further
disassociate these
homogeneous into single cells thereby
enabling
whole cell flow cytometry further we can
then sort those
samples and then go ask questions about
specific cell populations that we're
very interested in
what i date i showed you was we can sort
and enrich
for cancer cells thereby improving both
the
metrics around next generation
sequencing like tumor cell coverage
and the ability to detect clinically
relevant
variants so with that
i will end this presentation again i
would very much like to thank the
the organizers for inviting me
and uh this is the first time i've
actually put on a long sleeve shirt and
a bow
tie since march i thank everybody for
allowing me to have that opportunity
and i hope you appreciated the talk so
thank you very much